le reportage de patrick naf est prêt un
reportage sur la chute spectaculaire de
bernard hinault et sur l'état du
cycliste patrick bernard hinault blessés
à l'arrivée de la 14e étape
autrans saint-etienne diagnostic double
fracture des os propres du nez et
entaille au cuir chevelu
tous ces produits dans les 300 derniers
mètres lors du sprint du peloton
inovallée anderson whitney est âgé de
rennes s'accroche c'est la chute
une chute dont la cause reste
mystérieuse
l'autre victime de cette 14e étape c'est
le vainqueur le colombien luis herrera
qui tombe dans une descente à quelques
kilomètres de l'arrivée pelé à la
pommette et au front mais rien de grave
parti seul au 117e km le colombien a
franchi la ligne d'arrivée avec 47
secondes d'avancé sur ses adversaires
c'est sa deuxième victoire d'étape
derrière que l'esprit pour la seconde
place d'un sprint remporté par le belge
ludo peters devant le lieutenant de
bernard hinault l'américain greg lemond
et battre des records reste
le gros du peloton arrivera deux minutes
plus tard et comme le veut le règlement
des coureurs qui ont chuté dans le
dernier kilomètre sont crédités du même
temps pour ino d'onde
grosse frayeur mais pas trop de mal
rien si ce n'est qu'à ces deux points de
6,2 points de la tête et brest mais des
gens mais devra alors je pense que c'est
le plus important qui s'est passé dans
les sprints
il emmenait le sprint je crois que c'est
madiot qui a dû essayer d'allier et moi
j'ai pu chiper pour aller dans les
sprints avec rick lisible et ya un
courant qui arrivait sur le côté kamel
parce que c'est le foot d'anderson
j'ai pas vu le film je crois qu'il faut
voir le film pour savoir si c'est de sa
faute si c'est pas de sa faute
alors que comme ça jouer sur le côté de
la tête
aussi rien ça c'est rien deux fois la
marque de fabrique ici le nez cassé et
autrement le reste il ya rien du tout
montpellier au classement général
hinault conserve le maillot jaune et
greg lemond réalise une bonne opération
en reprenant plus d'une minute à stephen
roche et sean kelly 5e steve bauer